[Music]
uh so i did have
asked the patrons hey you guys always
want to ask us questions now's the time
to do it all right uh harrison
asked whatever happened to that to the
dog royce hat i remember an episode
where you guys had to leave early for a
medical emergency because the dog wasn't
feeling well she's doing good
she's sleeping right next to me right
now right too
he's lying i beat that dog to death you
want to come say hi
that's mercy she's she's streaming uh
let's see here i'm okay we're i'm not
even if we're gonna get to all of them
but
uh okay so jason this ques this question
got asked
like a bunch of times by a few different
people so this is one that a lot of
people want answered
uh my question would be how did you guys
first meet how did you first uh
do a project together uh what inspired
the rotc name and format
and the name is a is a bit of genius can
we pretend this was all a big
biographical question okay so
uh how did we first meet uh
well we uh we both we both were doing
our own we both were on our own shows
doing our own stuff you know and we we
we were on the same internet radio
stations back in the day before you
could stream on youtube and stuff
cringe humor radio ah consumer radio
that's where it was where we met the
radio and then those guys went on to
basically run the stand and then lose
the radio
lose the radio edge fm edge fm we were
so we were doing our own shows on there
and uh mike had moved from new york down
to miami
and when he was down there we used to
actually you know take a little shots at
each other when doing our own shows
that's the way it was
uh and uh when he when he came down to
miami he sent me a message he's like hey
man you know i'm in miami you want to
meet up
and uh we went out and we had a couple
beers
we went to this really fancy very
expensive uh
restaurant called flanagan's fancy we
got to keep that i believe it's french
we got to keep the cups too the big
green cups plastic
stupid cupcakes the flanagan cups
so uh yeah we met there and then uh the
first show that we did together
was uh the fifth circle mike would hop
on to like my hippo juice show and all
that stuff every once in a while
and we were talking like hey man we
should just do our own show we have good
chemistry together
and we started doing the fifth circle
and uh
after that you know uh i kept doing my
shows mike stop for a bit because he was
you know working
working man and uh well you came up with
the name mike if you want to answer that
part of the question
yeah i don't know it just sounded good
uh at the time
i don't know i think it dates a bit now
i don't think it's dating well but it's
not dating
funny in 2016 it was a cool name you
know what i mean
and i don't know it was just something
just like i i was pissed about
um a couple of things and then i started
getting down some rabbit holes
and then i got kind of [ __ ] spurred
out on the culture warship for a while
and yeah basically with uh when mde got
cancelled
that was like one of those where i was
like all right now they're pushing it
and then like i don't know i saw that
national geographic cover
like this was like four years ago when
they were when they were just starting
to roll out the like
kids stuff and it was like this six
seven year old boy on the well
girl i don't get in trouble on the cover
of national geographic that was like
they were like the the new face of the
future or whatever
then that was going on and then
pizzagate happened and then like
everything
i was just like all right and then i
went like full trumpsburg
and royce was like all right yeah we
should we could do like you know
it was like let's just do a show we try
to try to
keep that space alive because everybody
just kept getting whacked
and uh you know there was just there was
no like funny
like the left wing it usually is does
all the comedy and it's all woke garbage
and then the right wing generally just
takes itself too seriously
and uh needs to [ __ ] relax and
everything and they just like spread
doom porn so
we were like what if we just did a show
where the right wing was like fun and
cool
yeah and and you're right and we you
know we we started doing the show
and i mean we were just doing the show
man at the beginning for like maybe 20
people it was like friends and whatever
people listening and then
we kind of just took off from there not
saying that we're huge or anything
obviously we're not
um but the truth is we were inspired by
crowder
yeah we were like that [ __ ] guy man
he is
we want to be like him we want to be
like him and here we are mike
here we are because of him and as far as
that yeah the revenge of the sis name
you know mike and i were talking about
it but we're like you know
the cool the good thing about it is in
bali brought it up to you know revenge
of this might be data but just everyone
calls it rotc now anyway
so that's a good you know that that's
a good name it's a good name and also my
problems with the show whenever you're
promoting it to people
what's your name your show revenge of
the cis it's always like cyst like a
cyst
yeah you just say rotc now people go
wait so you're like uh
the military but for middle schoolers
and i just say yes
that's us that's us yep well we used to
[ __ ] with the rotc kids so much in high
school did you guys do that
oh yeah they were the easiest target man
those guys were awful
we basically helped create future
killers
i'm proud i feel like i should get some
sort of like maybe recognition from the
military for everything i did
to put the screws to those rotc kids in
high school
um they went on to probably they
probably got a lot of confirmed kills
and you know i mean you're welcome
military you're welcome america we saved
this country mike
yeah i we we sent some real coal
stone-cold killers
to iraq and afghanistan post 911
thanks to us just you know [ __ ] with
them all the time skateboarding through
their formations
the guy that killed that actually the
guy that killed bin laden sealed team
six that was the guy that went to my
high school i bullied him into doing it
yeah exactly i went to high school chris
kyle even though those numbers don't
match up at all
but say this bit i did and i was the one
that
i i taught chris kyle two things very
early on in life
how to shoot a gun and how to lie
through his teeth about every
accomplishment of his ever
well the same thing happened to me with
pat tillman i'm like man you're great at
football
but you know be better at being dead
and it worked way to god yeah i was like
i was we was actually we were
at football practice and i turned to pat
tillman and i was like you know what bro
don't you want to be like a hero and
then we got all drunk and stoned that
night and i was like dude i'm going to
join the military
and then me and pac got all riled up we
were going to join the military and then
i just kind of like woke up late the
next day and forgot
but pat joined go for him saving lives
man
save it well actually taking lives and
he won medals
he did you know what tillman never won
though a super bowl
all right i mean i know people get mad
when we say that but i'm sorry but would
you rather have tom brady's life for pat
tellman's life
tom brady all day are you kidding me i
want to be drunkenly throwing [ __ ]
artifacts off a boat
legally i mean we could technically do
that now but we would get in trouble
that man's name was tony romo nikki from
loop says
tony romo talked pat tony yeah we should
join tomorrow bro
and then rommel lied and he never joined
nah man i'm gonna be a color commentator
i have bigger plans i
want to be alive yeah the color
commentator for the nfl is a
slightly better survival rate yes